a Democrat with heft tells Biden to exit
stage left I speak of former Obama
strategist David
Axelrod who suggested that President
Biden drop out of the 2024 race yeah he
wants control yourselves you
animals yeah he wants Joe to reconsider
since his numbers are in
the he was responding uh to the poll we
mentioned earlier that showed Biden
trailing Trump in key battlegrounds
States including Arizona Georgia
Michigan Nevada and Pennsylvania true
he's sliding down more polls than a gay
firefighter I don't get that enough Axel
Rod posted on X that the data will send
Tremors of Doubt through the Democratic
party and create legitimate concern
about the president seeking reelection
when Gavin Nome heard that he screamed
thank you Lord
Satan and celebrated by dipping his head
in a vat of high performance
Valene axod concluded quote what he
needs to decide is whether that is wise
whether it's in his best interest or the
countries unfortunately axar didn't
specify which country America Ukraine or
China what say you
Joe no no no look look my interest are
the same interests align with the
country he doesn't know what he's
talking about Axel Rod I liked him
better when he played infield for the
Yankees let me tell you something
A-Rod I know you did peeds all right you
did peeds you admitted it so I got one
question for
you where can I get
some I need
them Joe do you think the other Joe is
worried do you think he even is aware of
this is going on he he has no clue he
has no clue I I like how some of the
Democrats think his age snuck up on them
yeah that it's like well first he was 78
then he was 79 followed that's how it
works yes but there is somebody waiting
in the wings uh there is and it's
somebody somebody who's got he's younger
he's got great hair he's great with the
ladies pleas come to California and
visit the great state he destroyed oh no
I mean hunter Biden oh okay good no okay
and I'll tell you why hun much rather
have him Hunter Biden would be awesome
because they talk about um you know
would they be awake for the 3:00 a.m.
call he's awake oh he's awake he's been
awake for a couple of days he puts the
call in call girl right so think of how
productive Hunter was when he was on
crack yeah right now I know if I lose my
laptop I'm out of work for a while he's
losing two or three at a time and didn't
even slow him down so I think he's the
man they got to put in that
place what do you think cat do you think
that uh he's going to be replaced was
like Axel Rod the first guy to step
forward I think Axel Rod's giving him
way too much credit actually yeah cuz he
said what he needs to do is
decide it's true not deciding anything
yeah there's no way you can look at that
guy and think he's making any kind of
decision right at all even like he
doesn't know what time he goes to bed
not up to him what time he wakes up like
like he doesn't have any idea what he's
doing next week right and I I I just
it's not the age thing I said this
repeatedly it's not the age thing it's
the fact that regardless of the age you
don't seem to be okay like
I he was a mess years ago I I yeah I I I
could not sit here and do that and and
like come back and do it again yeah I I
would be sent away somewhere they be
like all right cat you need to take like
90 days uh and go away he's actually
worse than bref and they got uh that's a
a former leader of the Soviet Union for
all you kids born after 1980 but uh they
at least acknowledged there was
something wrong there and I think they
replac him with an drop off who was then
dropped off dropped off I don't know
Emily do you think he has any idea by
the way way cat brings up a good point
it it's not about age it's really about
ability oh yeah of course not and that's
again the spin you hear from the left
where well Trump's old it has nothing to
do with age mental acuity that he has
none and when you have a loved one
that's deployed under his watch you know
it's stressful all the time under his
watch I I cannot express the level of
anxiety of lack of faith I have knowing
that it is him that is making those
decisions it is utterly frightening to
be an American right now under his watch
I have to say I feel like I'm like sort
of negative tonight but but the thing
about the Axel Rod stuff so remember
just last week when James Carville came
out and said top Democratic leaders are
telling me to shut up shut my mouth
about how Biden is horrible and and
essentially is going to lose right and
then all of a sudden David a David
Axelrod Obama's former strategist
strategist comes out and all of a sudden
is saying we need a new you know it's a
little late to change horses but three
times in that interview yes we should
have someone else think about about
who's behind everything and what now the
establishment that we are all subjected
to at this moment what decisions they're
making that's who's making the decisions
Carrot Top what do you mean he's the one
making yeah no the the prop comedian
said he's
behind got vegetables and fruits
confused Dr Drew uh where do you see
this going you know it's funny uh to
Emily's point though the majority
significant vast majority Democrats are
very happy with his administration they
don't really care that he's failing also
you've seen the multiple Falls that does
not predict the long life expectancy it
just is a simple statistical reality and
I prefer Joe's idea to Nome I got to
tell you please come to California it
will strike fear into your heart and
Hunter will start looking much more
appealing as a presidential candidate
just a medical question it's not for
anybody in particular uh would do you uh
do you have a certain number of Falls
over a lifetime
is the quota met yet yeah like you know
how many have you had lately well like
it's it's not me a friend of mine friend
a friend of mine had fall Falls
regularly generally yes should talk yes
okay coming up a phony newsman's demise
means you're in for a surprise hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else